عايزين نعرف في الموقع كما تشاهد امامك
هنا هذا حيث يوجد عدد من رجال الشرطه
ويوجد اثار للحطام هنا هذا الجزء الثاني
من المروحيه او جزء صغير منها سقط في هذه
المنطقه واحترقت هذه المنطقه هنالك ايضا
حفره طبعا الشرطه ما زالت تمنع الوصول الى
هناك اجار عدد كبير من الخبراء يجمعون
الادله هنا يوجد عمال الانقاذ الدفاع
المدني همم يوجد ايضا الشرطه همم في
الحقيقه همم قبل قليل شاهدنا بعض من همم
يعني اولياء امور الطلاب او همم الاطفال
الذين قتلوا هناك شاهدنا اسره وهم كانوا
في حاله صعبه همم ايضا قدم لهما
الاختصاصيين النفسيين المساعده همم هنا
كما تشاهد امامك في الصوره تماما هذا هو
رياض الاطفال الذي سقطت فيه هذه المروحيه
من الجهه اليسرى طبعا حتى الان المعلومه
طبعا ايضا تحدث الينا قبل قليل
كوليبا وهو قائد الاداره العسكريه في كيف
وقال ان الرقم الصحيح لعدد الضحايا هو 15
وليس 18 كان قلب لا ذلك قد نشر هو بنفسها
هذا الرقم 18 ولكنه عاده صحح الرقم بشكل
مباشر شفهي لنا قال ان الرقم الصحيح هو 15
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال هنالك 29 مصابا ايضا
بينهم عدد من الاطفال كذلك طبعا قال انه
المعلوم لدينا ان ركاب المروحيه كانوا
تسعه اشخاص قال لا استطيع عن ابوح بجميع
المعلومات ما نؤكده ان وزير الداخليه نعم
كان في هذه يستقيل هذه المروحيه كذلك نائب
وزير الداخليه هو وزير الدوله وكانوا في
ماموريه او في رحله عمل الى مناطق شده او
مناطق قتال مع طبيعه انه ما طبيعه هذه
المهمه التي كان يعني في الطريق اليها
الوزير وقال انه لا يستطيع ان يدلب مثل
هذه المعلومات كذلك طبعا البروتوكول يمنع
وجود ثلاثه مثل الوزير ونائبه وزير الدوله
في مروحيه واحده ايضا لانها عن هذا الامر
قال سوف نكشف في اليومين القادمين عن
تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه الحادثه لا استطيع
ايضا الحديث عن الامر طبعا ايضا همم يعني
بعض همم الاسر هنا وعدد من اهل الاطفال ما
زالوا موجودين في الموقع مازال العمل يتم
ما زال الخبراء يقومون بجمع الادله
والدفاع المدني ما زال يعمل في المبنى
كذلك الانقاذ ما زالت طبعا يعني في
البدايه كان من الممنوع الوصول الى الداخل
بالكاميرا ولكن سمحوا لي بشكل شخص يعني
ادخل وارى بعيني رايت يعني هنالك ضرر ليس
به صغير يعني هو كبير هنالك حريق في جزء
كبير من المبنى همم وهذا ما ناتج عنه هذا
الكم من الاصابات والقتلى همم طبعا ايضا
كما قال انه هنالك تسعه اشخاص كانوا في
المروحيه لم يكشف عن البقيه تتحدث عن
الوزير
ووزير الدوله ولكن بقيه الاشخاص في
المروحيه لم يكشف عن هويتهم وقال ان هذه
المعلومات السابقه لاوانها الحديث عنها
مازلنا في الموقع كما تشاهد وما زال
الخبراء يعملون ال- ال- ال- الحاجز
المضروب هنا ليس فقط حول هذا رياض الاطفال
او المنطقه الصغيره المحيطه الحاجز
المضروب من قبل الشرطه هو كبير جدا هو
مضروب في الحي تقريبا باكمله اكثر من سته
ولا سبعه بنايات هي مغلقه تماما لا يسمح
بالدخول بالخروج فقط الخبراء والمخصصه